you have to talk about composition of
your images but it's it's very difficult
to separate the idea of composition and
point of view background and even
lighting they all go together when you
adjust your light you will see later
you're going to get a different kind of
shadow and that shadow becomes part of
the composition so we have attempted to
separate them into three categories but
really they are very closely connected
and it's something to keep in mind so
let's start with these leaves these
autumn leaves that I put on a light box
which you will see more of when we talk
about light in fact the light box itself
is an important compositional element in
this image because it's giving us a very
strong negative space between the leaves
and it could be an interesting thing to
play around with using the background as
part of your composition something to
think about taking a look at these
crystals which I just randomly placed on
a background just to show the ability of
creating these crystals this is you know
an okay image by the way notice how the
shadows of these crystals become part of
a composition what I finally decided to
do was simplify the image and just
selected for crystals and made a more
close close up shot of them they're both
fine and that's one of these issues
about what's better i mean we could
split hairs and i really don't think
there's any we could argue either way
that's the fun part about this once
again there are no rules to any of these
things one of my gut ideas which has no
data associated with it is I think it's
more interesting to show two of
something rather than show one and I
suppose I could speak to some
psychologists and discuss whether we
really
to perceive it more I don't know I just
it's the way I do it and if I'm
suggesting that if you like what i do
then maybe you'll want to do it too I
did take these two devices by the way it
shows that you can do more than one to
create more than one and I photographed
it this way I photographed it in my
studio with a skylight above and notice
there's a little problem with depth of
field the one above is not really as
sharp as it should be and so I stopped
down which you know what that means so
that the aperture became smaller and we
I gave myself more depth of field that
is I got more in focus and what happened
was it got so much in focus that I could
actually see the detail of the skylight
with the clouds showing through this is
tangential to the point but it's all
connected and you have to really pay
attention and learn to see what it is
you're getting at eventually I wound up
I thought that this next image was the
best again using two and not necessarily
showing exactly the edge of each I think
it's an interesting idea to not
completely finish the image let the
viewer finish it more of a participatory
involvement perhaps once again this idea
of tues here are two balls that have so
small a pattern that we're seeing light
refracting and here are two silicon
chips that have material embedded on it
again I decided to do it in twos here's
another to do it too petri dishes of
e.coli growing by the way notice the
composition it's not exactly equal
equally divided I have one a little more
than the other for our book no small
matter we wanted to talk about
self-assembly actually these are tube
acrylic dishes with acrylic balls
that literally line themselves up and I
did it in twos as well you know again
it's an idea that I'm comfortable with
it's actually easier to compose when you
have two things least it is for me you
might give it a shot you might think of
using the process of composing your
picture as a means of telling a story a
visual story of what your devices are
about what you're seeing here you're
seeing basically three components of an
image you're seeing the underside of a
wafer on your upper left the green upper
left and that wafer has fabricated on it
small chips so the fuchsia color is what
the wafer looks like as a whole and then
we we have the individual chips on top
of the larger wafer so you'll see the
individual ones as well so we're trying
to sort of say this is a fabrication of
these particular tips that deliver drugs
that's why we wanted to show the
underside of the wafer I like all this
needs to be discussed in a caption none
of this works without text but this is
an attempt to visually describe what
this is in this next one these are
fibers that are constructed so that they
have different optical qualities and I
tried to weave them in a sort of a
fabric because that's what they were
thinking of making it work with they
wanted they were imagining these fibers
literally being woven into clothing I
don't know if it ever happened but this
is a number of years ago once again
telling suggesting the use of material
in this next one I was just playing
around with this was trying to show
glass when its treated properly you see
on the upper right and the lower right
when glass is treated in a certain way
it shatters properly and safety wise
where is the other one in the more
triangular area it's just not the way we
wanted it is a little too artsy probably
for many of you but again I was just
playing it and I do want you as I
continue saying to play with this stuff
the next one it was about corn that was
treated a particular way and I decided
to use the containers the plastic
material that it came in as a suggestion
of how these are delivered and finally
I'm you know just some devices that
evolved over time these are various
iterations of a particular idea and we
see how they changed how they evolved
telling a sort of a chronology of these
particular devices is an example of
really stretching our imagination it's
the watch that we've seen before on my
computer screen as well which I have
focused in on and we're seeing a detail
of the watch using the computer screen
as another light source but a
compositional one as well so here I'm
selecting the image of the watch on the
screen um I don't like the colors here
that's what we're doing here we're we're
basically going to be matching the
colors so selected the watch then
inverted selected the real watch as
opposed to the screen and now we have an
image that is balanced color wise just
imagine perhaps another kind of image on
your screen with your device maybe to
expand the explanation of how your image
works something that you might want to
think of using your own imagination so
this is just a hint of what you could do
with composition and as I said before
it's very difficult to separate this
idea of composition with point of view
and backgrounds which you'll see in very
shortly so you know it's all connected
and I could have very easily put some of
these
other categories but thought it would be
fun to just try for myself by the way in
separating them but they are truly very
much connected